dann würde ich langsam die kollegen die
foto kollegen bitten
platz einzunehmen es sieht sehr forciert
aus vielen dank liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen herzlich willkommen in der
bundespressekonferenz an sie alle hier
im wahl an alle die von den bildschirmen
verfolgen
wir freuen uns sehr dass wir auch in
corona zeiten hier in dieser stelle
pressekonferenzen organisieren und
veranstalten können und dass unsere
gäste trotz aller beschränkungen auch in
dieser zeit nach wie vor zu uns kommen
und ganz besonders freuen wir uns dass
wir heute bundeskanzlerin dr angela
merkel zur sommerpressekonferenz hier
begrüßen dürfen
frau bundeskanzlerin herzlich willkommen
in der bundespressekonferenz und
herzlich willkommen regierungssprecher
steffen seibert
weil diese pressekonferenz live
übertragen wird erlauben sie mir kurz
ein paar vorbemerkungen entgegen mancher
annahme hängen wir in der
bundespressekonferenz nicht mit der
regierung zusammen sondern wir sind
regierungsunabhängiger verein der
journalistinnen und journalisten über
die bundespolitik berichten
wir werden auf dem sender phoenix
begleitet von gewerben dolmetschen auch
in die kasse zu bekommen und ein dank an
könig sie diese dolmetscher für uns
ermöglichen und gewährleisten
noch ein paar organisatorische hinweise
die zahl der kolleginnen und kollegen
die hier im saal anwesend sein können
ist einfach durch die abstände stark
begrenzt deswegen werden wir heute auch
digitale fragen aufnehmen im wechsel mit
den fragen aus dem saal
mein kollege tim sind die bahn hier aus
dem vorstand der bundespressekonferenz
unterstützt mich und wird digitale
fragen stellvertretend für die kollegen
stellen
er sitzt hier im saal und die kanzlerin
wird zur eröffnung ein statement geben
und danach nämlich ihre fragen auf und
wir gehen einfach sozusagen
chronologisch durch und damit möchte ich
an die bundeskanzlerin übergeben
vermerken sie haben das wort ja guten
tag meine damen und herren ich möchte
mich natürlich bei der
bundespressekonferenz für die 1
einladung bedanken und danken auch dafür
dass sich die pressekonferenz so
ausrichten dass wir hier im saal die
regeln die in diesen zeiten nun einmal
gelten müssen auch einhalten können ich
grüße deshalb auch die journalisten die
deshalb heute nur im livestream dabei
sein können genauso herzlich für die die
hier im saal sind als ich im letzten
jahr meine neujahrsansprache hielt
konnte ich mir und so geht es
wahrscheinlich auch ihnen wahrlich nicht
vorstellen was uns dieses jahr 2020
bringen würde dass eine pandemie staaten
gesellschaften volkswirtschaften in
aller welt vor nie dagewesene
herausforderung stellen würde
und auch für uns in deutschland sind die
monate seit februar märz ein tiefer
einschnitt und für jeden von uns haben
sie das leben dramatisch verändert
privat und in der familie am
arbeitsplatz in unserem demokratischen
zusammenlebens
das virus ist eine demokratische
zumutung und seit über einem halben jahr
bestimmt dementsprechend auch das kona
virus meiner arbeit als bundeskanzlerin
und aus heutiger sicht scheint mir ganz
klar dass das auch im winter und im
herbst erst mal und dann im winter so
bleiben wird
ja man muss damit rechnen dass manches
in den nächsten monaten noch schwieriger
sein wird als jetzt im sommer wir alle
haben ja im sommer die freiheiten und
den relativen schutz vor erosion
genossen die sind möglich dass es
möglich durch das leben draußen und in
den nächsten monaten wird es jetzt
darauf ankommen die infektionszahlen
niedrig zu halten wenn wir uns wieder
drinnen aufhalten an arbeitsplätzen in
schulen und in wohnungen forscher
weltweit arbeiten zwar so intensiv wie
sie vielleicht noch nie das getan haben
auch medikamente und einen impfstoff
gegen das virus hin aber noch haben wir
beides nicht wir werden noch länger mit
diesem virus leben müssen und deshalb
ist meine grundhaltung eine der
wachsamkeit der aufmerksamkeit gerade
jetzt da die infektionszahlen wieder so
deutlich über die
diesen wochen gestiegen sind das macht
uns sorgen und deshalb habe ich auch
gestern gemeinsam mit den
ministerpräsidenten weitere beschlüsse
gefasst und es bleibt dabei es ist ernst
unverändert ernst und nehmen sie es auch
weiterhin ernst
dieses letzte halbe jahr gibt mir aber
auch zuversicht denn wir alle zusammen
bürger und staat haben es gemessen an
der herausforderung bis hierher wirklich
gut bewältigt schlimme erfahrungen das
erlebnis zeitweise völlig überforderter
krankenhäuser wie sie leider auch einige
unserer engsten partner ja durchmachen
mussten sind uns bisher erspart
geblieben
das war nur möglich wäre er ein sehr
starkes gesundheitssystemen in den
kalender ganzen fläche unseres landes
haben und vor allem weil die
überwiegende mehrheit der menschen in
deutschland vernunft
verantwortungsbewusstsein und
mitmenschlichkeit gezeigt hat und ich
werde für diese millionenfache
reaktionen der menschen immer dankbar
sein
die bundesregierung hat in diesem halben
jahr intensiv gearbeitet für den schutz
der gesundheit jedes einzelnen für unser
gesundheitssystem als ganzes für den
erhalt unserer wirtschaftlichen basis
und unserer arbeitsplätze
sie haben dafür mutige entscheidungen
getroffen zusammen mit dem deutschen
bundestag und den bundesländern auch
gerade in dieser woche im
koalitionsausschuss und bei der
gestrigen konferenz mit den
ministerpräsidenten
wenn wir jetzt so langsam in den herz
gehen dann sind es drei schwerpunkte
drei ziele die ich nennen möchte die für
mich in diesen kommenden wochen von
besonderer wichtigkeit sind erstens
alles dafür zu tun dass unsere kinder
nicht verlierer der pandemie sind ihre
bildung ob kita oder schule muss mit das
allerwichtigste sein und ich meine alle
kinder egal aus welchem familienumfeld
die schule darf niemanden zurücklassen
die direkte verantwortung für den
schulunterricht liegt natürlich bei den
ländern
denn jetzt noch den ferien unter
beachtung von infektionsschutz regeln zu
organisieren dass es wirklich eine der
schwierigsten aufgaben im land
zurzeit ich habe mich neulich zusammen
mit der spd vorsitzenden fristen und der
ministerin anja karliczek mit einigen
kultusministern getroffen um klar zu
machen
auch die bundesregierung sieht unter
diesen außergewöhnlichen umstände eine
mitverantwortung für sich und der werden
wir über den digital packt hinaus mit
einem großen beschaffungsprogramm auch
gerade für die digitale ausstattung von
lehrern nachkommen und in einigen
anderen projekten auch zweitens unser
wirtschaftsleben so weit wie möglich am
laufen zu halten oder wieder zum laufen
zu bringen
die substanz unserer unternehmen die
basis unseres wohlstands und die
arbeitsplätze zu erhalten und auch in
der krise gerade in der krise die
zukunftsfähigkeit die innovationskraft
deutschlands zu stärken
das heißt zum beispiel klimafreundliche
technologien digitalisierung
vorantreiben die grundlagen legen für
das nächste kapitel der energiewende die
nutzung von wasserstoff und schließlich
die dritte priorität unserer arbeit in
der pandemie den gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalt so weit wie möglich zu
bewahren
die pandemie belastet menschen sehr
ungleich sie mache ganze gruppen der
bevölkerung besonders verwundbar ich
denke an ältere menschen an
pflegebedürftige und ihre angehörigen an
familien mit kindern in beengten
wohnverhältnissen studierende den deren
nebenjob wegfällt arbeitssuchende die es
jetzt wieder mehr gibt und die es
schwerer haben kleinunternehmer die um
ihre berufliche existenz bangen künstler
und künstlerinnen auf sie alle müssen
wir besonders achten immer wieder
versuchen zu unterstützen und angebote
zu machen und vor allem und dazu trage
ich bei euch im mund auch alle
mitglieder der bundesregierung immer
wieder mit diesen gruppen im gespräch
bleiben
es hat sich so gefügt dass deutschland
in dieser krisenhaften phase bis zum
ende des jahres die eu
ratspräsidentschaft innehat
auch sie steht ganz im zeichen der
pandemie und leider sind viele
begegnungen und gipfel die wir hier in
deutschland durchführen wollten auf die
wir uns gefreut haben schlicht nicht
möglich
aber das ändert nichts an
unsere europäischen ehrgeiz und einsatz
mit dem wir die präsidentschaft anpacken
im mittelpunkt steht jetzt natürlich
diese union der 27 mitgliedstaaten gut
durch die krise
und wieder stark herauszuführen
und das geht nur gemeinsam in
solidarität niemals wenn wir in ein
jeder für sich zurückfallen würden dass
es direkt vor der sommerpause noch
gelungen ist einen historischen
wiederaufbau von und den eu haushalt bis
2027 zu beschließen das war ein guter
start für die präsidentschaft
ich bin froh dass deutschland und
frankreich mit der initiative die
präsident marc und ich ergriffen haben
einen wichtigen beschluss für die
wichtigen bei impuls für die beschlüsse
geben konnten
jetzt muss in den verhandlungen mit dem
europäischen parlament die nicht ganz
einfach werden alles daran gesetzt
werden dass der wiederaufbau form auch
wirklich zum jahresanfang 2021 wirksam
werden kann
denn die mitgliedstaaten das wissen wir
alle warten dringend auf diese mittel
für europa gilt was auch für deutschland
gilt in der krise dürfen wir erst recht
nicht die augen nicht aus den augen
verlieren womit wir die zukunft gewinnen
wollen
und das heißt auch auf eu ebene werden
wir uns für eine entschiedene und
ambitionierte klimapolitik einsetzen
wir werden immer wieder die themen
innovation und digitalisierung betonen
europa muss da wo der zukünftige
wohlstand erarbeitet wird entweder
anschluss finden oder besser noch es
muss von anfang an vorne mit dabei sein
zwei themen die auf europäischer bühne
in den kommenden wochen noch stärker
nach vorne drängen werden und dann auch
die präsidentschaft beschäftigen werden
will ich noch kurz nennen den dreck
zieht wo es auf die entscheidenden
wochen jetzt zugeht in denen wir das
künftige verhältnis zwischen
großbritannien und der eu zu klären
haben und die gemeinsame europäische
asyl und migrationspolitik wo wir
vorschläge in kürze von der kommission
erwarten
und dann beschäftigt uns natürlich die
außenpolitik mit ihren vielen vielen
themen über die wir sicherlich jetzt im
verlauf der pressekonferenz noch
ausführlich sprechen werden deshalb so
weit eine alles als andere vollständig
der einführung meinerseits in einige
wichtige themen und jetzt freue ich mich
auf ihre fragen vielen dank dafür
nochmal nach tag eine organisatorische
ergänzung wir haben eine zeitliche
begrenzung von eineinhalb stunden und
wegen der fülle der fragen würde ich sie
bitten sich auf eine frage ebenfalls
eine nachfrage zu beschränken
ich rufe sie chronologisch auf gewerbes
nicht thematisch sortieren und wie
gesagt in wechsel online fragen aufrufen
und die erste frage hat frau
bundeskanzlerin vor fünf jahren sagten
sie an dieser stelle wir schaffen das
ist das ein satz der ihn in der kroner
krise eigentlich auch über die lippen
gekommen werden sie sich aber verkniffen
haben weil sie erlebt haben dass dass
das land auch polarisiert hat und was
hat in den fünf jahren wer oder was hat
in den fünf jahren sie am meisten
geschafft soziale hier also geschafft
hat mich endlich nichts aber gefordert
hat mich sicherlich vieles ja vor fünf
jahren habe ich den satz und einer sehr
speziellen situation gesagt ja auch eine
große herausforderung ist dieser satz
steht für sich manchmal der sich sogar
ein bisschen zu sehr verselbstständigt
aber egal wir haben seitdem sehr viel
zustande gebracht und wenn ich mir sage
dann sind das viele viele menschen die
geholfen haben viele verantwortliche auf
allen ebenen aber auch viele geflüchtete
die zu uns gekommen sind und wenn man
sieht dass einige von ihnen jetzt abitur
machen und studiengänge aufnehmen dann
zeigt sich dass auch hier viel geleistet
wurde
und insofern ist mir jetzt nicht hier
sind gekommen diesen satz zu wiederholen
jede krise und jede herausforderung hat
ihre eigenen ihre eigene sprache und
insofern glaube ich sind wir uns heute
alle bewusst ich habe nicht umsonst eben
wieder das thema migrationspolitik
genannt auch als herausforderung für
unsere präsidentschaft jetzt denn die
wahrheit ist es gibt noch kein in sich
geschlossenes system einer europäischen
migrationspolitik
es bleibt also auch da noch vieles zu
tun aber auch das kann man schaffen wenn
man will
frau bundeskanzlerin ich hört sich ganz
gerne zum deutsch-russischen verhältnis
fragen wir haben doch eine reihe von
ereignissen die einiges in einem anderen
licht erscheinen lässt sich wenn man so
kurz die tiergarten mord die
cyber-attacke auf den bundestag mögliche
einflussnahme russlands auf die
entwicklung in belarus die vergiftung
des oppositionellen navalny es gibt
stimmen die sagen man müsse deswegen die
politik gegenüber russland ändern wollen
sie diese politik ändern und wenn ja was
soll sich da ändern
nein das glaube ich nicht dass wir sie
ändern müssen denn ich meine ich kann
ihnen genau so viele fälle aus der zeit
davor nennen wenn ich an die annexion
der krim denke an die unsere bemühungen
nach wie vor in der ukraine
wenigstens mal einige tage keine toten
zu haben an die frage des kriegs
attentats also es ist etwas was wir als
durchgängige linie ja doch sehen
das belastet natürlich immer wieder das
deutsch russische verhältnis auch das
europäisch russische nicht umsonst haben
wir im zusammenhang mit der ukraine auch
sanktionen und ich kann jetzt nur hoffen
ich war ja auch mit dem russischen
präsidenten darüber im gespräch dass
gerade bei weißrussland die souveränität
des landes auf geachtet wird und die
menschen dort ihren gehen können
wenngleich gestern auch gerade die es
wegfahren von journalisten die
einschränkung der journalistischen
freiheit natürlich zeigen dass das alles
andere als einfach ist
wir haben immer trotzdem gesagt wir
müssen mit russland im gespräch bleiben
es gibt eine vielzahl von
internationalen themen wenn ich an
syrien denke wenn ich an libyen denke wo
russland auch über das direkte
verhältnis hinaus das bilaterale
verhältnis hinaus einfach ein
geostrategischer akteur ist der mit dem
man im gespräch bleiben muss und
natürlich ist das ziel nach wie vor von
uns gute beziehungen zu haben russland
ist ein riesen land mit einer langen
geschichte mit seiner großen kultur und
dieser spannungsbogen zwischen dem was
wir auf der einen seite erleben und auf
der anderen seite eben auch immer das
gespräch zu suchen
der wird uns auch in den nächsten
monaten sicherlich begleiten dann haben
wir zu diesem thema eine frage aus dem
digitalen hier sitzen
der kollege philipp von der russischen
abschneidet ast russland soll nach
angaben von putin eine reservetruppe der
polizei für weißrussland aufbauen darum
habe ihn präsident lukaschenko gebeten
sagt putin in einem tv interview
wie bewerten sie diesen schritt ich
hoffe dass eine solche truppe nicht zum
einsatz kommt und dass wie es schon eben
sagte die kräfte die jetzt mutig auf die
straße gegangen sind die menschen die
missstände benannt haben dass sie das an
freiheits möglichkeiten haben was wir
für uns als selbstverständlich annehmen
können demonstrationsfreiheit
meinungsfreiheit für all das muss
bekämpft werden und weißrussland und das
ist das anliegen der menschen und das
sollen sie eigenständig ohne einmischung
von außen aus jeder richtung auch
realisieren können das ist unser wunsch
herr blank frau bundeskanzlerin bei mir
bei der außenpolitik geben wir zum
erdgas streit zwischen griechenland und
der türkei
es hieß sie würden heute mit dem
türkischen präsidenten erdogan
telefonieren haben sie das getan haben
das vielleicht vor
und wie bewerten sie die rolle
frankreichs in dem streit
frankreich hat sich ja da klar auf die
seite griechenlands gestellt also ich
glaube dass wir alle
als mitgliedstaaten der europäischen
union das die aufgabe haben natürlich
die rechte und die dinge die unsere
griechischen freunde vorbringen sehr
ernst zu nehmen und sie auch zu
unterstützen wo sie recht haben
dennoch habe ich mich immer wieder dafür
eingesetzt dass es zu keinen weiteren
eskalation kommt und das geht zum teil
eben nur dadurch dass man auch mit
beiden seiten immer wieder spricht und
die dispute die es dort gibt über die
aufteilung der wirtschaftszone sind
können auch nur gemeinsam geführt werden
dafür setzt sich deutschland ein ich
habe mit dem präsidenten markt sehr
intensiv über das verhältnis zur türkei
gesprochen das ja sehr vielfältig ist
die türkei als nato partner
der konflikt ist im grunde einer
zwischen zwei nato mitgliedsstaaten es
kann uns ja nicht kalt lassen sondern
auch da auch schon aus dem grunde muss
man versuchen innerhalb des bündnisses
die dinge zu klären
ich habe im übrigen ansonsten heute
nicht mit herrn erdogan besprochen werde
es auch heute nicht mehr tun bin aber
sehr häufig mit ihm im gespräch und wie
immer werden wir sie umgehend
informieren wenn es statt gefunden hat
dann wenn ich bei herrn jung merkel sie
hatten die demokratischen zumutungen und
auch die kinder angesprochen und in
ihrer einleitung dazu nur frage kostet
was wusste was ist wolle scheint er die
losung bei der bekämpfung der korona
panini zu sein mit radikalen maßnahmen
einschränkungen versuchen sie die
gesundheit der bevölkerung zu schützen
der klimawandel ist aber eine noch
größere bedrohung für die kinder aber
auch für meine generation und gefährdet
ebenfalls massiv die gesundheit radikale
jetzt notwendige maßnahmen scheitern
aber wenn sie mal erklären was aus ihrer
sicht diese beiden bedrohung aus
politischer sicht unterscheidet also
jeder bedrohung erfordert ihre reaktion
und das tun wir bei der nab anämie
natürlich nicht koste es was es wolle
sondern möglichst koste ist so wenig was
es wolle an menschenleben so wenig wie
möglich über forderungen unseres
gesundheitssystems zu wenig
möglich arbeitsplätze so wenig wie
möglich schulstunden die ausfallen also
das ist das was unser leitgedanke dabei
ist und die klima herausforderung ist
auch eine globale wie im übrigen auch
die korona pandemie vielleicht gibt es
auch mehr zusammenhänge als man denkt
weil es immer um einen nachhaltigen
lebensstil geht und einen nachhaltigen
lebensweg vielleicht lernen wir ja auch
aus all diesen oder ich hoffe wir lernen
aus all diesen herausforderungen auch
etwas sowohl im umgang mit der
artenvielfalt auf der welt als auch eben
mit der emission von klimaschädlichen
gasen und ich glaube dass wir gerade im
blick auf die klima herausforderung doch
in den letzten jahren entschiedene
schritte gegangen sind und europa hier
auch der erste co2 freie kontinent sein
will und wir werden auch aus sehr
[Musik]
praktischen gründen unsere anstrengungen
hier in den nächsten jahren sicherlich
eher beschleunigen als verlangsamen weil
wir auch sehen wenn der klimaveränderung
zum teil unsere lebensgrundlagen bedroht
aber noch viel stärker afrikanische
lebensgrundlagen dann hat das wieder was
mit flucht und mit migration zu tun das
heißt also die dinge die uns politisch
begegnen die hängen alle sehr zusammen
und insofern unterscheide ich nicht in
der hierarchie zwischen den einzelnen
herausforderungen sind beide
lebensbedrohlich und beide sehr groß war
ja warum gelingt es ihnen den menschen
und zu wieder wirtschaftsschutz von
corona ungekannte härten zuzumuten aber
nicht beim klimawandel und frau kunz
hatte gerade schon den satz mit wir
schaffen das genannt auf eine nachfrage
beschränken was sind denn eigentlich
ihre leitsprüche die korona pandemie und
den klimawandel haben sie die ich kann
nur nochmals sagen dass wir glaube ich
wenn sie von unbekannten herzen sprechen
das sind zum teil hätten für menschen
für gruppen das ist richtig da gibt es
aber auch zumutungen im zusammenhang mit
den klimamaßnahmen da gibt es auch wenn
sie mit bergarbeitern zum beispiel
sprechen die im kohlebergbau arbeiten
die
dass ihre existenzgrundlagen vernichtet
werden auch das müssen wir in kauf
nehmen weil es einfach notwendig und
dringlich ist aber immer versuchen wir
natürlich dort wo es herten gibt auch
abzufedern
das sind die bisher nicht dagewesenen
hilfsprogramme die wir jetzt in der
kroner pandemie aufgelegt haben und das
sind die unterstützungsprogramme zum
beispiel für den kohleausstieg die auch
von einer großen dimensionen sind also
wir versuchen auf die herausforderungen
adäquat zu reagieren
ich glaube es ist jetzt eine nachfrage
gewesen wir haben weiter eine frage aus
dem digitalen dazu passen klimaschutz
julian wird engel fragt sie wurden in
der vergangenheit häufig als
klimakanzlerin bezeichnet haben selbst
betont wie wichtig und 40 bei der
klimaschutz ist was haben sie in ihrem
letzten jahr als kanzlerin vor diesem
anspruch gerecht zu werden auch im
hinblick auf die rolle deutschlands in
der eu und der un und morgen mit blick
auf die klimakonferenz in glaskugeln
lesen ja ich unterstütze das ziel der
kommissionspräsidentin ursula von der
leyen nämlich die den europäischen
kontinent das heißt die europäische
union zum ersten
co2 freien kontinent oder damit auch zu
einem jedenfalls weiten teilen des
kontinents zu machen
das ist eine sehr ambitionierte aufgabe
die noch sehr viele veränderungen von
uns verlangen wird denn die zeit ist ja
nicht mehr lang wir feiern jetzt den
dreißigsten jahrestag der deutschen
einheit und werden wir mal 30 jahre
weitergehen und sie wissen alle wie kurz
30 jahre im blick auf so etwas sein
können dann haben wir das jahr 2050
und dann müssen wir co2 neutral sein das
heißt dass es eine sehr überschaubare
zeit eine zeit im übrigen für die die
für die jungen klima aktivistinnen und
aktivisten natürlich eine ist in der sie
dann gerade sozusagen in der mitte ihres
arbeitslebens stehen und deshalb müssen
wir jetzt die 2030er ziele für die
europäische union anpassen die
kommission wird dazu einen vorschlag
machen wenn ich das recht verstehe ende
september müssen die mitgliedstaaten
darauf reagieren
ich hoffe dass es uns gelingt nicht nur
für die industrie emissionen ein
zertifikatehandel einzuführen sondern
auch für die mobilitäts emissionen und
die wärme emission denn das preissignal
das haben wir gelernt ist das wichtigste
signal um veränderungen mit sich zu
bringen
wir sehen jetzt schon dass wir durch die
höheren zertifikate preise zum beispiel
sehr viel weniger strom aus braunkohle
produzieren und insofern hier auch doch
durchaus veränderungen sehen durch durch
erhöhte preise was glasgow anbelangt so
wird es darum gehen und dafür deshalb
müssen wir als europäische union da uns
natürlich auch darauf vorbereiten dass
man die nationalen ziele die der
einzelnen mitgliedstaaten verbessert
denn bis jetzt ist die summe aller
anstrengungen auf der welt noch nicht
eine die uns dazu führen wird den
klimawandel oder die temperatur anstieg
auf 15 grad celsius zu beschränken
aber vor allem geht es jetzt erst mal
darum in deutschland unseren
ambitionierten klima programme
umzusetzen und in europa einen
gemeinsamen fahrt zu finden wir haben
noch nicht alle mitgliedstaaten der
europäischen union die sich auf das
thema neutralität ziel 2050 verständigt
haben
polen hat sich das dem noch nicht
angeschlossen auch da müssen wir noch
die einheitliche linie der europäischen
union herstellen
florian neuen zdf frau bundeskanzlerin
noch mal ein grundsätzliches frage zum
thema corona gesundheitsminister sparen
hat den satz geprägt dass man sich nach
dieser krise manches wird verzeihen
müssen welche fehler haben sie
selbstkritisch in den letzten monaten
gemacht hat die bundesregierung gemacht
den sie vielleicht wo sie vielleicht um
verzeihung bitten müssen ich finde dass
wir bislang nach besten wissen und
gewissen entschieden haben ich glaube
dass wir immer wieder lager angebot
passt unsere maßnahmen verändern müssen
das haben wir jetzt ja auch als lehrer
aus der reisesaison gesehen dass wir
eben doch sehr viele reisen in
risikogebiete hatten wo wir jetzt
veränderungen vornehmen werden aber ich
glaube dass wir sehr viel miteinander
auch gerade mit den bürgerinnen und
bürgern gemeinsame dinge hinbekommen
haben und insofern bin ich eigentlich
mit dem dank der ereignisse bis hierher
einigermaßen zufrieden und es gibt
herten
das ist gar keine frage für dazu gruppen
die habe ich ja eben genannt große
härten und da muss politik dann eben
auch versuchen gerade in diese richtung
besonders viele maßnahmen zu ergreifen
um das abzufedern und nicht alles wird
wieder so sein wie vor der korona fanden
die trifft uns schon art und
existenziell
aber wir könnten uns jetzt ja auch sehr
vieles leisten im sommer wenn ich an die
vielen möglichkeiten von urlaub gedacht
habe mit ein bisschen vernunft und
beschränkung können wir gut durch diese
zeit kommen kurze nachfrage wenn sie
sagen keine fehler keine großen fehler
wenn sie zum beispiel in die bude
urlaubsrückkehrer denken haben sie da
nicht zu spät reagiert man hätte ich ja
früher wissen können dass
urlaubsrückkehrern eine mögliche gefahr
darstellen also
wir haben sicherlich vielleicht nicht in
dem umfang gesehen dass menschen in
risikogebiete fahren ich habe auch nicht
gedacht dass zum beispiel ganz spanien
jetzt wieder zu einem risikogebiet
erklärt werden musste aber das ist doch
es ist doch entwicklungen die können wir
doch auch gar nicht voraussehen also in
einer solchen entwicklung in einer
solchen nie gesehenen herausforderung
kann per se immer nur entschieden werden
auf dem was wir heute wissen und was
dann morgen ist das geht dem
wissenschaftlern so das geht uns in der
politik so und das muss man nach besten
wissen und gewissen abwägen und wenn es
notwendigkeiten gibt muss man nach
steuern
das wird es auch weiter gehen kein
mensch weiß wie der winter abläuft wir
kennen das virus nur ansatzweise seine
eigenschaften alles was wir jetzt zum
beispiel über eine uno schule gelernt
haben in den letzten wochen das war am
anfang nicht bekannt da ist man bei
einer tröpfcheninfektion ausgegangen und
wann immer wir neues wissen müssen wir
auch neue maßnahmen treffen jetzt zum
beispiel unsere belüftungsmaßnahmen die
wir wo wir fördern werden dass man die
belüftungsmöglichkeiten verbessert das
wird ein ständiger prozess
man hat zwei fragen aus dem digitalen
matthias gebauer vom spiegel fragt frau
bundeskanzlerin für viele deutsche sind
corona tests mittlerweile eine art
normalität geworden egal ob bei
verdachtsfällen in den schulen oder der
rückkehr aus dem urlaub wie oft haben
sie sich als regierungschefin schon auf
das virus testen lassen und wie sehr
fürchten sie sich selbst vor einer
möglichen infektion mit dem virus
also ich habe ja schon in quarantäne
gesessen und weiß deshalb wie das ist
und das 14 tage auch ganz schön lang
sein können selbst wenn man gut
beschäftigt ist zu hause in dem
zusammenhang bin ich mehrere male
getestet worden also insofern kenne ich
den vorgang des testens ansonsten halte
ich mich an die abstandsregeln und dann
die vorschriften und
bin deshalb jetzt nicht so dass ich
permanent getestet werden sondern wie
gesagt das beschränkt sich auf die zeit
der der quarantänezeit da war ich froh
dass die tests negativ
eine weitere fahrt zum thema cora
stephan langer von der augsburger
allgemeinen fragt von bundeskanzlerin
sie haben unter anderem anfang mai
gesagt das sei wichtig dass ein koma
impfstoff allen menschen zugute kommt
wenn er einmal entwickelt wurde
zitat bislang scheint es eher so zu sein
als ob jeder staat seine eigene
strategie fährt sind sie mit den zusagen
der staatengemeinschaft zufrieden
das kann ich so nicht bestätigen wir
haben mehr verschiedene initiativen
einmal die europäische herangehensweise
zusammen auch mit ausgewählten
mitgliedstaaten jens spahn hat das
begonnen mit einigen mitgliedstaaten das
hat die kommission jetzt federführend
übernommen
dafür auch europäische gelder zur
verfügung gestellt das ist jetzt mit den
astrazeneca mit einem der hersteller zum
ersten mal ein vertrag der europäischen
union abgeschlossen worden an weiteren
solchen verträgen wird gearbeitet also
innerhalb der europäischen union achten
wir sehr darauf dass wir fair und
friedlich miteinander
die zur verfügung stehenden potenziell
zur verfügung stehenden dosen teilen und
wir sind ja im internationalen verbund
engagiert ist hat eine reihe von
nun also von geberkonferenzen gegeben im
zusammenhang mit der frage dass auch die
länder die entwicklungsländer sind an
den medikamenten und impfungen dann
teilhaben können deutschland hat sich
hier auch mit erheblichen finanziellen
beiträgen beteiligt aber auch mit
einsatz sich selber haben wir an vielen
solchen konferenzen teilgenommen die
kommissionspräsident dann hat das
vorangebracht ich bin
wir sind mit der gates-stiftung den
kontakt mit der initiative cpi mit gabi
mit der bio
also hier wird schon sehr konzentriert
darauf gearbeitet und wir gehören zu
denen die sich dafür einsetzen dass
genau das genannte ziel auch erreicht
werden kann
in dem saal bei händlern frau
bundeskanzlerin sie haben gesagt dass
sie die berliner entscheidung die
demonstration am wochenende zu verbieten
respektieren
nun ist es aber so dass die
bundesregierung weltweit auf die
einhaltung der versammlungsfreiheit
während hier in berlin demonstrationen
von möglicherweise zehntausenden dieses
wochenende verboten werden sehen sie da
einen widerspruch sind sie bereit sich
mit vertretern dieser recht der og
bewegung zu treffen so wie ich es mit
dem aktivisten oder bauernverbänden
getan haben also ich hab nur hinzugefügt
das in deutschland ja ein rechtsstaat
ist und das selbstverständlich
diejenigen die jetzt die demonstration
angemeldet haben auch den gerichtsweg
gehen können das gehört für mich dazu zu
der demonstrationsfreiheit und ansonsten
entscheide ich immer dann wenn menschen
sich an mich wenden ob ich jetzt mit
ihnen das gespräch suche oder nicht hat
es bei ihres wissens nach einer wird
gegeben und mir ist eine solche bitte
nicht bekannt
linke und das ganze auch nicht gerade
zum thema cola und wirtschaft kommen
die koalition hat er jetzt etliche
maßnahmen länger hat kostet milliarden
wie groß ist ihre sorge dass der staat
in dieser krise auch finanziell
überfordert werden kann weil viele von
diesen maßnahmen sich sehr teuer
herausstellen dass diskussion gibt ob
nicht unternehmen künstlich am leben
gehalten werden ist dem großen schock
also danach irgendwann staatliche hilfen
wegfallen und fürchten sie kein
ungleichgewicht durch diese sehr starke
deutschen hilfen in europa jetzt auch
mehrere fragen also der der ich glaube
dass es absolut notwendig war die
stützungsmaßnahmen durchzuführen und ich
glaube dass sich auf eine ganz
unerwartete und auch nicht erwünschte
art und weise gezeigt hat dass es gut
war dass wir in den vergangenen jahren
sehr sparsam und ordentlich
gewirtschaftet haben dass wir einen
ausgeglichenen haushalt hatten dass wir
mit unserem schuldenstand wieder in
richtung des der maastricht-kriterien
oder die maastricht kriterien
eingehalten haben
es war gut dass wir reserven bei den
sozialen sicherungssystemen hatten
allein bei der bundesagentur für arbeit
ba über 18 jahre alt war 28 milliarden
euro
das hilft uns jetzt natürlich in diese
zeit hinein zu gehen und auch wirklich
die notwendigen hilfen leisten zu können
wir stehen natürlich bei jeder
entscheidung vor der frage ist das eine
brücke die wir bauen die auch dann
tragen kann in die zukunft das ist
vollkommen klar das ist im falle einer
pandemie besonders schwer zu entscheiden
weil wir ja nicht wissen wann sie endet
wir wissen nicht wann es einen impfstoff
gibt wir wissen nicht wann es ein
medikament gibt als wir die bankenkrise
hatten da wusste man wenn man die banken
rekapitalisiert dann hat man die ursache
der krise beseitigt und dann kann man
wieder zurückkehren zu einem
vernünftigen normalen wirtschaften hier
wissen wir dass nicht ob das noch drei
monate dauert oder
zehn oder zwölf oder 15 monate und
insofern ist das schon eine nicht
gekannte herausforderung für unsere
finanzielle tragkraft bei der ich glaube
dass wir alles was wir bisher
entschieden haben uns leisten können und
dass wir immer auch im auge haben müssen
was würde das nichthandeln bedeuten wenn
es dann mal wieder vorangeht und
vielleicht fachkräfte ihren bezug zum
unternehmen verloren haben siehe das
thema kurzarbeit oder eben fachkompetenz
wieder herbei geführt werden muss es
wird der tag kommen an dem es wieder
messen gibt und große veranstaltungen
und wo messebauer und all diese menschen
gebraucht werden wenn man die jetzt alle
um schuld um anschließend festzustellen
dass man jetzt wieder alle messebauer
ausbilden muss dann ist das auch keine
besonders ökonomische verhaltensweise so
dass ich für die zeit ist vor also für
den jetzigen zeitpunkt sagen kann ist
und wir haben handeln verantwortlich
wir gehen nicht zu weit in die zukunft
hinein aber wir dürfen auch nicht
monatliche unsicherheit schüren sondern
es muss auch eine belastbare grundlage
sein das hat uns jetzt ja auch bei den
entscheidungen zum zum kurzarbeitergeld
sehr bewegt wir wissen dass wir zu denen
dann gehören wir sind nicht das einzige
mitgliedsland der europäischen union
aber wir gehören zu denen die sich
relativ viel also stützungsmaßnahmen
leisten können und genau das war auch
der grund warum ich mich dafür
eingesetzt habe zusammen mit dem
französischen präsidenten dass wir hier
diesen ungewöhnlichen weg gegangen sind
auch zuschüsse in form von darlehen
durch die europäische kommission
auszugeben an diesen zuschüssen
profitieren andere mitgliedstaaten sehr
viel stärker als deutschland und das ist
auch richtig so weil die pandemie
unverschuldet über alle mitgliedstaaten
gekommen ist wir haben eine vielzahl von
darlehensprogrammen zum beispiel zur
zahlung von kurzarbeitergeld mit diesem
programm schuhe und insofern versuchen
wir also auch die kollision und die
konvergenz innerhalb der europäischen
union aufrecht zu erhalten auch wenn wir
etwas mehr tun können und stellen dies
auch europa mit zur verfügung unsere
stärke
fähigkeiten dann nehmen wir mal fragen
aus dem digitalen dazu ich habe zwei
fragen die sich mit der cdu beschäftigen
der kollege koller von der saarbrücker
zeitung fragt frau bundeskanzlerin
es gibt drei kandidaten für den cdu
vorsitz 2 haben sie in ihren ländern mit
großer medienbegleitung besucht werden
sie werden sie herrn röttgen in
ähnlicher weise öffentlich treffe ich
habe jetzt von herrn röttgen noch keine
einladung bekommen
insofern ist konnte ich darauf auch noch
nicht reagieren das ist sicherlich
strukturell etwas schwieriger werden mit
dauer trocken arbeite ich ja im
deutschen bundestag zusammen bezug auf
die fragen gerade auch der außenpolitik
sehr eng und sehr gut im übrigen bei den
anderen beiden handelt sich sehr um bei
dem einen bei den beiden besuchen die
ich gemacht habe
handelt es sich ja um
ministerpräsidenten was bayern und in
nrw anbelangt und friedrich merz habe
ich ja auch noch nicht
öffentlichkeitswirksam jetzt getroffen
sondern wir haben uns gesprochen also
wenn es gesprächsbedarf geht das tue ich
aber mit norbert röttgen auch eine
zweite frage
von kerstin münstermann funke
mediengruppe die spd hat ihren spd
kanzlerkandidaten gekürt die cdu
beschäftigt gerade vor allem die suche
nach einem vorsitzenden was raten sie
ihre parteien diese situation mit blick
auf die nächste bundestagswahl ja
fraumünster man weiß ja auch dass ich
mich als diejenige die für das amt der
bundeskanzlerin und auch nicht kann mehr
kandidiert auch nicht mehr cdu
vorsitzende ist aus diesem
nachfolgefragen heraus halte deshalb hab
ich da auch keine hinweise und zu geben
dann bin ich im saal war flog am sonntag
die redaktions netzwerk deutschland
bundeskanzlerin am nordring 2 die liste
an konflikten mit den vereinigten
staaten ist lang
was würden vier weitere jahre unter 1
präsidentin trump für das verhältnis zu
washington bedeuten und können sie die
aussage des früheren botschafters grüne
bestätigen wonach sie wurden danach von
seinem hattrick
sie verzaubert hätte was hätte er
verzaubert ach so berichte berichte aus
internen gesprächen nicht und insofern
kommentiere ich das jetzt auch nicht
aber sie wissen dass ich immer gesagt
habe und kann das auch gerne wiederholen
dass ich mit jedem gewählten präsidenten
der vereinigten staaten von amerika
zusammenarbeit was uns dabei leitet sind
unsere werte und natürlich von deutscher
seite von amerikanischer seite auch die
interessen und dass deshalb das
amerikanische volk die entscheidung am
vierten november treffen wird und wir in
deutschland auf unsere wahlen
konzentrieren und in den vereinigten
staaten von amerika man sich auf die
dortigen wahlen konzentriert dass es
hier und da meinungsverschiedenheiten
gibt das liegt in der natur der sache
aber es gibt auch eben gemeinsame dinge
und gerade was die nato anbelangt so ist
das glaube ich eine gemeinsame
überzeugung dass senator ein wichtiges
sicherheitspolitisches bündnisses in
dass deutschland sich auch natürlich
einbringt da ich noch überschlagen etwa
30 fragen auf der liste habe bitte ich
noch mal darum sich tatsächlich auf eine
frage zu beschenken und bin im saal bei
frau frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben
vorgestern mit dem polnischen
premierminister morawski telefoniert
gibt es da auch um das große deutsch
polnische problem gerade das problem des
deutschen botschafters der seit drei
monaten auf die akkreditierung aus
warschau erwartet und sehen sie das als
ein affront gegenüber berlin dass diese
hinausstellung so kommt ich hoffe dass
sich das thema das der akkreditierung
des botschafters
löst aber im wesentlichen ging es um die
frage geht aus und die frage was können
wir hier aus der europäischen
perspektive unterstützend tun brauchen
wir zb einen repräsentanten der sich
speziell um die frage belarus kümmert
entweder bei der eu oder auch bei der
osze um die frage wie können wir auch
gerade menschen die gefoltert wurden die
verletzt wurden die krank sind
unterstützen und um die sanktionen die
wir gegen belarus unternehmen wollen und
hier gibt es eine große zahl von
übereinstimmung zwischen dem polnischen
zwischen der polnischen sicht und der
deutschen kurzer nachfrage weil sie das
ansprechen
gestern wurden über 30 journalisten auch
ausländische deutsche journalisten in
minsk entsprechend schlecht behandelt
verhaftet und behinderte an der arbeit
wie wollen sie darauf reagieren
naja wir werden uns wo immer wir können
für die journalistische freiheit und die
guten arbeitsmöglichkeiten einsetzen ich
hab das eben schon im zusammenhang mit
einer anderen frage gesagt dass das was
gestern stattgefunden hat natürlich das
gegenteil davon ist für das was wir wo
wir einstehen und das werden wir
sicherlich weißrussland auch mitteilen
dass wir das nicht akzeptabel finden
medien
frau bundeskanzlerin frage zum thema
wirecard sind die erkenntnisse die wir
die sie auch in den letzten wochen und
monaten zu diesem unternehmen gesammelt
haben ein anlass für sie sich bei
auslandsreisen vorsichtig zurückhaltend
da für deutsche unternehmen einzusetzen
und warum waren diese erfahrung nicht
ein anlass für sie und ihre regierung
auch ministerien das bundeskanzleramt in
die transparenzpflichten eines
lobbyregister im gesetzentwurf der
koalition mit einzubeziehen
ich glaube dass wir durch das
informationsfreiheitsgesetz
schon sehr verantwortlich oder
rechtliche grundlage haben sehr
transparent zu arbeiten
sowohl in richtung der öffentlichkeit
aber auch durch das instrument der
fragen die ja in kleinen und großen
anfragen nicht und zahlreiche auf uns
einstürmen jeden tag dass wir also durch
diese instrumente doch als regierung
eine sehr hohe transparenz darlegen und
insofern haben wir ja dann auch auf die
anfragen zu wirecard hingewiesen das was
da passiert ist muss natürlich
aufgeklärt werden das ist klar aber es
dass es passieren kann dass man zu einem
zeitpunkt wo man von solchen
unregelmäßigkeiten keine kenntnis hat
man sie für ein unternehmen auch
einsetzt das halte ich auch für gegeben
das war ein dax 30 unternehmen und
insofern haben wir da glaube ich für den
nach dem damaligen kenntnisstand
verantwortlich gehandelt so wie wir
überhaupt natürlich immer den
unterschied sehr deutlich machen
zwischen dem unternehmerischen handelns
und dem unternehmerischen risiko aber es
ist usus nicht nur in deutschland dass
man bei auslandsreisen natürlich die
anliegen von unternehmen auch anspricht
das macht man nicht nur in china
es gibt es auch bei anderen
auslandsreisen natürlich wir waren dann
wieder ans netz
ich habe mehrere fragen zum thema
lieferketten gesetz stellvertretend der
pflege buchsteiner von mediatoren frau
bundeskanzlerin wie zufrieden sind sie
mit den plänen von entwicklungsminister
müller und arbeitsminister helfer
eingesetzt dass mindeststandards an
globalen lieferketten sichern soll
hat dieses vorhaben ihre ungeteilte
unterstützung das vorhaben als häufig
ist es ja teil des koalitionsvertrags
und hat meine unterstützung aber
natürlich muss wir müssen jetzt die
zuständigen ressorts vor allem und das
ist neben dem entwicklungsministerium
dem sozialministerium auch das
wirtschaftsministerium einen gemeinsamen
entwurf wir wollen das erst mal von
eckpunkten vorliegen dazu gibt es
zurzeit sehr intensive diskussionen und
ich werde auch wert darauf legen
dass auf der einen seite das wirklich
wichtige anliegen fairer lieferketten im
fokus ist dass auf der anderen seite
aber auch natürlich die dinge machbar
sind für insbesondere mittelständische
unternehmen die natürlich nicht immer
alle informationen für alle teile der
lieferkette haben können das heißt es
wird eine schwierige abwägung werden uns
sicherlich noch ein sehr kompliziertes
gesetzgebungsvorhaben was aber teil
unseres koalitionsvertrags ist und das
will ich auch dass es umgesetzt wird
dann bin ich bei frau bauer
nehmen sie das mikro bitte wann hat man
sie besser
hallo frau bundeskanzlerin ich würde
gerne schnell vertretend für einen
zuschauer von uns eine frage stellen er
hat nämlich ein gefühl formuliert das
sicherlich sehr weit verbreitet ist in
der bevölkerung so die sorge dass man
jetzt langfristig mit diesen regeln
leben muss und es nie wieder so wird wie
zuvor er fragt sich probiert man aus
münchen fragt sich wann kann der bürger
damit rechnen dass alles wieder so wird
wie früher
und was ist so der maßstab die hoffnung
machen ja es wird nicht so wie früher so
lange wir kennen im stoff und kein
medikament haben weil wir sonst durch
dinge die uns ja wirklich lieb sind hand
schütteln uns umarmen
zwischen menschen die nicht in einem
haus stand wurden also dinge die nähe
sind weil wir sonst damit andere in
gefahr bringen können
und wenn es einen impfstoff gibt oder
sehr sehr gute medikamente dann wird man
natürlich sofort wieder zu den uns
eigenen verhaltensweisen auch
zurückkehren können aber die hoffnung
kann nur darin bestehen dass wir mit der
krankheit so umgehen können dass sie uns
nicht gefährdet und vor allen dingen
auch die risikogruppen nicht gefährdet
danach gab weil es gibt schon erste
fälle bei denen trotz erkrankungen
anfang des jahres jetzt keine antikörper
beispielsweise mehr nachweisbar sein was
wenn das mit der impfung gar nicht
funktioniert ja das gibt es ja eine
breite wissenschaftliche debatte bei
denen ich wirklich jetzt nicht die beste
gesprächspartnerin bin wie weit
antikörper notwendig sind um einen
impfstoff zu entwickeln also wie die
beiden dinge zusammenhängen das weiß ich
nicht ich höre nur aus der entwicklung
szene der medica der impfstoffe dass es
ja doch sehr hoffnungsvolle ansätze für
impfstoffe gibt nach den verschiedenen
methoden und insofern drücken wir mal
die daumen wir tun alles in dem wir auch
sehr stark ökonomisch wirtschaftlich
fördern diese impfstoffentwicklung das
tun nicht nur wir auf der welt sondern
viele andere auch und wenn man überlegt
wie viele jahre ist sonst gedauert hat
impfstoffe zu entwickeln dann ist jetzt
schon sehr viel anstrengung dahinter und
wirklich auch kraft und wille das
voranzubringen
dann bin ich mein ziel
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben den eu
aufbauplan schon angesprochen
der koalitionsausschuss von montagabend
am dienstagabend schon angefangen und
sage ich mal das geld ein bisschen zu
verteilen sondern digitale
bildungsoffensive gehen geld schont auch
den kohle ausstieg weil wir ergänzt oder
die infrastrukturmaßnahmen drumrum
fließen können sie uns sagen welche
weiteren investitionsschwerpunkte sie
dafür deutschland sehen weil es da
fließen jedoch beträchtliche mittel
und haben sie vielleicht aber dennoch
sorge dass es vielleicht gar nicht dazu
kommen könnte weil die ratifizierung zum
beispiel im bundestag schalter nachdem
ihr vizekanzler ja und seinem gesäß
zentrale argument der einmaligkeit
dieses vorhabens in frage gestellt hat
und als dauerhaftes projekt vorstellen
kann
also ich glaube dass und hoffe werde
alles dafür tun dass diese ratifikation
natürlich stattfindet im deutschen
bundestag
ich habe ja auch deutlich gemacht für
mich ist das eine aus dieser speziellen
situation herauskommen da einmaliger ein
einmaliger kraftakt der aber auch
notwendig ist wir werden übrigens die
schulden aus diesen
wiederaufbau von bis 2058 zurückzahlen
das heißt also das ist jetzt auch nicht
wie in der nächsten legislaturperiode
beendet da hat es noch nicht mal richtig
angefangen
und insofern glaube ich auch dass auf
der grundlage
die fraktion der ich angehöre ihre
zustimmung geben wird wir werden für ein
deutscher seite nach jetzigem stand man
kann das noch nicht ganz genau sagen
weil ein teil des geldes jahr nach einem
bestimmten schlüssel noch mal berechnet
wird etwa 22 milliarden euro bekommen
die regeln sind so dass es sich um
maßnahmen handeln muss die nach dem
zwanzigster januar 2020 in den
nationalstaaten beschlossen wurden und
dass sie eine antwort geben müssen auch
auf die defizite die im zusammenhang mit
den länderspezifischen empfehlungen der
kommission an die einzelnen
mitgliedsstaaten
benannt wurden da ist gerade bei
deutschland das thema
zukunftsinvestitionen immer eins an dem
die kommission auch gesagt da müssen wir
mehr machen
deshalb wird ein großer teil des geldes
sicherlich aus dem kommen was wir uns im
konjunkturprogramm schon vorgenommen
haben und was noch nicht durchfinanziert
ist aber sie haben schon erwähnt wir
werden auch noch mal einen schwerpunkt
setzen bei der digitalen bildung bei der
dazu notwendigen infrastruktur wir haben
dann eine zweite komponente die ist
nicht direkt dieser aufbau von sondern
das ist der just transition fand das ist
ein dass das geld was aus dem wir auch
etwas bekommen wenige milliarden zur
begleitung des umstiegs aus kohle in
andere technologien und die werden ein
fließen in das 40 milliarden
unterstützungsprogramm für die kohle
regionen und damit sie ihre anpassungen
besser bewältigen können
ab 15 oktober bis zum 15 oktober soll
man oder das soll können die ersten
einfach anträge eingereicht werden wir
werden uns als regierung mühe geben sehr
schnell anträge einzureichen und auch
gerade auf die themen digitalisierung
und klimaschutz hier besonderen wert zu
legen also im bereich wasserstoff
technologie könnte ich mir etwas
vorstellen
ich könnte mir etwas vorstellen in dem
bereich auch der digitalisierung hatten
wir schon gesagt die der finanzmittel
das finanzministerium und kanzleramt
werden jetzt mal einen vorschlag machen
auf der basis der des rahmens denen wir
aufgespannt haben dann wären wir das mit
den ressorts und den fraktionen
abstimmen und ich hoffe dass wir dann
relativ zeitgerecht mit einer am anfang
gleich unsere vorhaben einreichen können
denn das ziel muss ja sein das geld
möglichst schnell auszugeben ich hatte
heute nicht so viel davon das jetzt
lange hinzuziehen denn es muss in der
zeit sein wo wir noch voll mit dem
wirtschaftseinbruch zu tun haben dagegen
zu investieren und
eben auch in die zukunft zu investieren
es geht mir meines titan
ich muss leider das thema mobbing
fortsetzen aber sonst wenn wir das hier
nicht abarbeiten können
frau meyer von der taz frau
bundeskanzlerin beim parteitag im
dezember über die diebe die cdu über
eine verbindliche frauenquote von 50
prozent bis 2025 abstimmen wie werden
sie importieren und warum ist dieses
thema in ihrer zeit als vorsitzender
nicht längst umgesetzt worden
ja wir haben ja jahrelang uns mit dem
chrome beschäftigt und dessen umsetzung
jetzt geht man einen schritt weiter das
finde ich auch richtig und deshalb werde
ich aus vollem herzen zustimmen wenn die
bundeskanzlerin
wir arbeiten hat sich ja insofern in der
korona krise auch verändert als sie
ich formuliere es mal zugespitzt
eigentlich sich hauptsächlich nur in
ihrem amt aufhalten können sie können
keine auslandsreisen machen
sie können auch im land ja wenig
firmenbesuche oder ähnliches absolvieren
hat sich eigentlich ihre art des
arbeitens und ihr zeitmanagement
verändert kann man vielleicht sogar mal
grundsätzlicher über dinge nachdenken
oder wie würden sie das beschreiben
na ja es hat sich natürlich die art des
arbeitens verändert denn sonst geht ja
auch sehr viel zeit für reisen auf also
ein paar reisezeit muss aufgebracht
werden das ist jetzt nicht der fall das
ist ja nicht immer die produktivste zeit
auf der anderen seite vermisse ich das
schon ein bisschen dass man jetzt doch
sehr wenig raus kommt das ist auch
richtig was natürlich eine vollkommen
neue entdeckung ist das ist das thema
der videokonferenzen wo ich sagen muss
dass das sehr viel besser geht als ich
mir das haupt vorstellen können
videokonferenzen mit sehr großen gruppen
sind recht
natürlich doch eher statische aber
videokonferenzen mit gruppen von zehn
bis fünfzehn menschen sind sehr intensiv
und zum teil gar nicht schlechter wenn
man sich ab und an mal sieht oder wenn
man sich gut kennt gar nicht mehr
schlechter als wenn man längere reise
macht und oder alle anderen an reisen
lässt und wenn man ganz neue dinge
besprechen will meinetwegen das thema
wiederaufbau von wo auch sehr viele und
mittelfristige finanzielle vorausschau
für die zeit zwischen 2021 und 27 und
weiß dass man das nur durch
gruppengespräche aber dann auch wieder
individuelle gespräche also mit stark
wechselnden formaten machen kann dann
sind videokonferenzen unzulänglich das
muss man ganz klar sagen video konferenz
nahmen auch den nachteil dass man nicht
weiß wer alles zuhört das kann man in
geschlossenen räumen doch etwas besser
kalkulieren und einschränken und
insofern gibt es einige unterschiede
aber durch videokonferenzen kann man
auch seinen tag mit einer sehr hohen
dichte an aktivitäten füllen weil man
sicher genauso vorbereiten muss wir auf
jeden anderen gesprächstermin
aber das jetzt so sehr viel mehr zeit
bleibt um tagelang grundsätzlich
nachzudenken dicke bücher zu lesen und
irgendwie über die welt von übermorgen
nachzudenken das kann ich noch nicht
bestätigen
eine nachfrage noch was sich ja auch
verändert hat im vergleich zu diesem
zeitpunkt in den früheren
legislaturperioden ist dass sie sich
keine gedanken mehr machen müssen über
den bevorstehenden cdu-parteitag und
ihre kanzlerkandidatur waren sie da
manchmal morgens auf und denken sich ein
glück dass ich das nicht mehr machen
muss
ich glaube dass es mir so nach dem motto
alles hat seine zeit natürlich ist das
eine besondere zeit wenn ich jetzt nicht
darüber nachdenken wie sie der nächste
wahlkampf aus das ist klar aber das gibt
mir die möglichkeit mich in dieser
herausfordernden zeit jetzt doch sehr
auch aufs regieren konzentrieren zu
können ich meine das ist jetzt wie wir
sitzen jetzt hier und jeder zweite platz
ist nicht besetzt und wir wissen dass
das ganze branchen gibt die überhaupt
nicht richtig arbeiten können wir jetzt
mal ein künstler denke wenn ich an ich
schon die messen genannt wir wissen wie
eltern jeden morgen aufstehen und am
samen ob ihr kind jetzt irgendwie eine
laufende nase hat und das wird sicher
zwischen ganzen winter ziehen dass das
natürlich total nervenaufreibend wir
müssen gucken wie wir dann trotzdem das
ganze land am laufen halten und
vielleicht ist es jedenfalls empfinde
ich nicht als nachteil dass ich mich
voll auf diese aufgabe konzentrieren
kann weil das schon etwas ist was wir
doch gar nicht kennen
und es ist ja auch gut und vernünftig
dass wir immer wieder ein großes stück
von routine in unseren alltag bringen
auch unter diesen veränderten umständen
aber es ist schon eine eine sehr sehr
sehr besondere zeit
und was ich als gut empfinden um das
auch noch zu sagen ist dass sich
natürlich durch meine langjährige
politische erfahrung sehr viele akteure
schon kenne
wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel im ersten
jahr bundeskanzlerin wäre und hätte
sozusagen die allermeisten staats und
regierungschefs auf der welt noch gar
nicht gesehen und man könnte jetzt nicht
reisen und würde das alles immer nur
über video konferenz machen müssen das
wäre schon sehr viel einschneidender und
insofern ist das jetzt zur zeit auch
schon ein bisschen hilfreich dass ich
schon viel gereist bin und auch viele
kenner der umstand dass man nicht so
genau weiß
dazu hat das haben wir auch hier
deswegen
eine unbekannte fahrer aus dem digitalen
nein nicht ändern kann
aber sie passt ja schon dazu der kollege
herr holz vom korrespondentenbüro er als
frage frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben
einmal gesagt sie träumten davon durch
die rocky mountains zu reisen und mit
der transsibirischen eisenbahn durch
russland zu fahren
haben sie schon gebucht oder was sind
ihre pläne für den ruhestand
nein ich habe noch nicht gebucht und es
ist auch nicht gerade nicht die zeit
danach
solche reisen zu buchen bin voll
beschäftigt mit der ist zeit
was sind ihre pläne für den ruhestand
ja dass die haben sich jetzt mal nicht
so dramatisch geändert ich könnte das
wieder antworten und ansonsten habe ich
mir noch keine gedanken gemacht ich
werde jetzt erstmal noch weiter arbeiten
und dann wird sich das finden ich bin
optimistisch dass wir was einfällt dann
bin ich bei frau markmeier frau
bundeskanzlerin bettina marx spd jetzt
ich muss möchte und muss nochmal einmal
auf das krone thema zurückkommen sie
haben jetzt auch mehrfach von den
besonders verletzlichen gruppen
gesprochen und den menschen die
besondere härten zu ertragen hatten
ich möchte die besondere härten hatten
die heimbewohner zu ertragen die wochen
land isoliert waren
ich würde von ihnen gerne wissen
ob das wieder vorkommen kann oder ob sie
sicher sind verhindern zu können dass es
wieder vorkommt ich glaube dass er
inzwischen genug gelernt haben um
sicherzustellen dass es so wie es war in
den ersten wochen nicht wieder vorkommt
will aber nicht verhehlen dass ich mir
insgesamt sorgen mache um die frage wie
sich die verschiedenen gruppen in
unserer gesellschaft sozusagen
weiterentwickeln
wir haben jetzt ja sehr viele infizierte
junge menschen
das durchschnittsalter der infizierten
ist ungefähr um 20 jahre gesunken
wir haben zurzeit sehr sehr wenig
erkrankungen glücklicherweise bei den
älteren und und ich frage mich natürlich
woran liegt das und es kann natürlich
auch daran liegen dass sich eine ganze
gruppen unserer gesellschaft sehr
zurückziehen aus der öffentlichkeit und
eben nach wie vor mit wenigen
kontaktpersonen klarkommen müssen längst
nicht so viel rausgehen können und
deshalb ist die frage der gegenseitigen
rücksichtnahme natürlich schon von
großer bedeutung denn eine gesellschaft
in der jeder ältere den jüngeren aus dem
weg geht sozusagen die spalten
lebenswelten entstehen vollkommen
gespaltene das wäre auch nicht so gut
deshalb freue ich mich dass bei den
umfragen wird auch heute wieder sehr
sehr viele menschen auch verständnis
haben für die regeln die wir haben weil
es ja nicht nur um mein leben geht in
einer gesellschaft sondern auch um das
leben anderer
also ich glaube so es wird so wird es
nicht wieder sein wie wenn es etwas
besser machen können aber es werden
trotzdem sind ja nach wie vor noch
beschränkungen da frau bundeskanzlerin
nach einer stunde noch mal zurück zur
ersten frage wir schaffen das 2015
würden sie aus heutiger sicht
die wesentlichen entscheidungen von
damals noch mal genauso treffen und
stehen sie auch noch zu ihrer
feststellung von damals dass sie sagten
die grenzen deutschlands ließen sich
nicht schließen
ich würde die wesentlichen
entscheidungen wieder so fällen das ist
richtig und ich glaube dass man das
haben wir gemacht man kann grenzen
kontrollieren aber man kann muss die
frage wenn so viele menschen kommen die
kann man nicht auf dem rücken der
menschen austragen das ist meine
überzeugung wenn menschen vor der
deutschen österreichischen oder
österreichisch-ungarischen grenze zu
grenze stehen dann muss man sie als
menschen behandeln und muss dann
anschließend das habe ich ja dann auch
getan mit der türkei zum beispiel über
ein abkommen verhandeln wie wir menschen
vor ort helfen das ist vollkommen klar
aber ich würde die wesentlichen
entscheidungen wieder so hätte er fällt
mir dann noch eine frage aus dem digital
ich habe mehrere fragen zu dem rücktritt
des japaner angekündigten rücktritt des
japanischen ministerpräsidenten unter
anderem von vordenker von der
japanischen tageszeitung yomiuri shimbun
sehr geehrte frau bundeskanzlerin der
japanische ministerpräsident ist
zurückgetreten was bedeutet dieser
rücktritt politisch für die
internationalen beziehungen und für sie
persönlich
ich hatte natürlich noch keine
gelegenheit bis hin zur arbeit zu
sprechen jetzt aber ich bedaure
natürlich diesen rücktritt wünsche ihm
auch vor allem gesundheitlich alles gute
wir haben immer sehr sehr gut
zusammengearbeitet und hatten jetzt auch
in der korona zeit noch eine
video-konferenz miteinander
ich glaube dass ich in diesen zeiten
unser deutsch japanisches verhältnis
recht gut entwickelt hat hinzu arbeit
ist sozusagen der längst die nächste
ministerpräsident japans gewesen als er
hat japanische geschichte jetzt auch mit
geprägt er war immer jemand der sich für
multilateralismus eingesetzt hat und
auch über die großen entfernungen
zwischen japan und deutschland hinweg
auch deutlich gemacht hat wo in unsere
unser gemeinsames wertefundament besteht
also ich wünsche ihnen von herzen
gute und bedanke mich für eine gute
zusammenarbeit
dann bin ich im saal bei herrn
leithäuser frau bundeskanzler ich würde
sie gerne fragen ob sie den
syrien-konflikt als die grösste
aussenpolitische travel die in ihrer
amtszeit ansehen und ob sie in der
rückschau lehren ziehen aus dem
verhalten deutschlands europas und des
westens insgesamt in diesem konflikt
hätte man da was anders machen müssen
ich bin mir nicht leider nicht sicher ob
es die größte tragödie ist weil das was
ich im jemen abspielt an humanitäre
katastrophe leider auch in derselben
region auch sehr sehr sehr dramatisch
ist und alles was mich viel mehr als vor
zehn jahren in der sahelzone beschäftigt
natürlich auch lügen auch von großer
bedeutung ist aber syrien ist schon eine
eine dramatische situation wenn man
überlegt dass die hälfte der bevölkerung
syriens im grunde entweder im land auf
der flucht ist oder das land verlassen
hat wenn man sieht dass man mit recht
gegen einen diktator vorgehen wollte der
letztlich immer noch im amt ist dann
spürt man was für ein spannungsfeld
zwischen den werten für die man kämpft
und für die ich auch kämpfe und auf der
anderen seite zwischen den möglichkeiten
ist wenn man jetzt nicht militärisch
agiert es hat russland hat sich nicht
gescheut sozusagen dem hilferuf an assad
nachzukommen und das hat natürlich
nochmals einer verfestigung der
situation dort geführt und es ist bis
heute kein inklusiver politischer
prozess zustande gekommen bei denen ich
auch mit dem russischen präsidenten sehr
oft gesprochen habe und ich werde mich
solange ich im amt bin natürlich sehr
dafür einsetzen dass die vielen menschen
die heute nicht mehr in st
sind oder die in syrien vertrieben sind
auch ihre syrische stimme bekommen aber
es ist es ist eine große tragödie bei
der sich die hoffnungen dass dessen was
man arabischen frühling genannt hat
natürlich ihr gegenteil verkehrt haben
wir noch ein ziel tage um ihre fragen
zum fall bahrain hier unter anderem von
ernst franceschini us-journal herrn
alleiniges laut charité vergiftet worden
wird daher in berlin behandelt und
geschützt befürchten sie nicht dass
solche aktion des kreml immer dreister
und brutaler werden auch in deutschland
und der eu
wenn die reaktion darauf milde und
rhetorisch bleiben wie bisher
das der fall war ich glaube dass er die
pflicht haben alles zu tun damit das
aufgeklärt werden kann es war richtig
und gut dass deutschland gesagt hat der
sind bereits ich danke auch den ärzten
einer bei der charité herr navalny
aufzunehmen und jetzt werden wir mit
unseren möglichkeiten die in der tat
begrenzt sind versuchen die
aufklärungsarbeit zu führen und wir
werden auch das versuchen wenn wir mehr
klarheit haben über die hintergründe
ähnlich wie man dass er bei hans
kripperl hatte dann auch durchaus eine
europäische reaktion zu haben nicht nur
einzelstaatliche reaktionen wenn ich ein
deutsches problem das auch wenn
deutschland jetzt herbei aufgenommen hat
die zweite frage zum digitalen unter
anderem von herrn basiere freien novosti
es gebe in deutschland die meinung aus
dem projekt nord stream zwei deshalb
auszusteigen wie können sie das
kommentieren halten sie es für möglich
dass deutschland aus diesem projekt
aussteigt oder sollte es ihrer meinung
nach fertiggestellt werden und er
bezieht sich ausdrücklich auf den fall
dabei
ich habe ich glaube dass wir das davon
entkoppelt sein sollten und dass
die unserer meinung ist dass jung 2
fertiggestellt werden sollte es ist ja
ein projekt was von wirtschaftsakteuren
aus russland und aus europa betrieben
wird das heißt es ist hat zwar
politische implikationen deshalb haben
wir uns auch dafür eingesetzt dass es
weiter ein transitvertrag zur
gaslieferung zwischen russland und der
mit dem transit weg ukraine gibt und
werden das auch weiter tun aber dieses
wirtschaftliche getrieben über
wirtschaftlich getriebene projekt jetzt
mit der frage navalny zu verbinden halte
ich nicht für sachgerecht und wir sind
auch gegen die externe tollen sanktionen
die die vereinigten staaten von amerika
dort aufgelegt haben das heißt also hier
wollen wir das was fertig gebaut wird
und die frage nach einigen wie andere
fragen tiergarten und ähnliches müssen
separat diskutiert werden dann bin ich
knapp dahinter bei herrn shazam frau
bundeskanzlerin die großen fraktionen im
europaparlament haben in dieser woche an
sie appelliert klare regeln zur
koppelung von eu geldern an
rechtsstaatlichkeit durchzusetzen
in dem brief heißt es also der nächste
eu haushaltsrahmen ohne eine lösung
dieser frage nicht geschlossen werden
könne
gibt es ihrer meinung nach eine gefahr
dass das parlament seine zustimmung zum
ff verzögern könnte um den rechtsstaats
mechanismus zu stärken und ist die
deutsche eu präsidentschaft dazu bereit
sich für einen stärkeren mechanismus
einzusetzen aus derjenige der auf dem
europäischen rat im juli beschlossen
wurde
ich habe ja die verhandlungen vier tage
lang mitgemacht und es ging dabei nicht
nur um geld sondern es ging auf genau um
diesen rechtsstaats mechanismus und die
verhandlung dieses teils war gehört zu
den kompliziertesten in der gesamten
verhandlungsphase von den vier tagen das
heißt ich weiß ungefähr wo die
spielräume sind es muss auf der einen
seite eine mehrheit des europäischen
parlamentes gefunden werden die den
vorschlägen zustimmt das weiß ich
deshalb nehme ich die kommentare und die
bemerkungen des europäischen parlaments
auch sehr ernst wir sind ja dazu auch im
gespräch mit dem parlamentspräsidenten
und den fraktionen und auf der anderen
seite weiß ich auch wie es um die
kompromissmöglichkeiten innerhalb des
europäischen rates steht denn wenn das
parlament eine mehrheit zustande bringt
aber der europäische rat nicht
einstimmig zustimmt dann ist es auch
nicht möglich das heißt wir haben es
hier auf der einen seite mit der
einstimmigkeit der mitgliedstaaten zu
tun und müssen hier das maximale
herausholen und auf der anderen seite
haben wir es mit wie ich finde auch
berechtigten grundhaltungen des
parlaments zu tun und was man da zu
einem bestimmten zeitpunkt erreichen
kann
und woran man weiter wird arbeiten
müssen das müssen wir jetzt miteinander
ausloten ich lege jedenfalls viel wert
darauf dass wir auch zu einem
wiederaufbau von und zu einem haushalt
kommen und trotzdem sind dann noch es
dann noch eine quadratur des kreises zu
schaffen
wenn ich in den letzten reihen link
finden bei hansa bank ja hallo frau
wurde erwürgt anfragen ob sie angesichts
der katerstimmung
weißrussland belarus ob sie sich auch an
ihre eigene geschichte etwas erinnert
fühlen vor 30 jahren oder auch in berlin
wurde menschen willkürlich verhaftet und
auch mitgenommen wurden geschlagen
danach wurden sie auch aktiv in
opposition demokratische opposition in
der ddr eine frage ist finden sich auch
ein bisschen daran erinnert was ihre
message auch um die menschen in belarus
in diesen tagen hunderttausende auf die
straßen gehen aber der diktator im
gegensatz zu amerika zum beispiel nicht
abgedreht ist und ja und im gegensatz zu
damals
doch die unterstützung von moskau hat
einerseits fühle ich nicht erinnert und
andererseits weiß ich dass die umstände
doch jetzt ganz anders sind
damals konnten wir die friedliche
revolution in der ddr nur erfolgreich
gestalten weil letztlich die sowjetunion
es hat geschehen lassen gorbatschow weil
nicht eingegriffen wurde als die mauer
geöffnet wurde
weil auch der ganze vorherige weg
möglich war ohne dass die sowjetunion
sich eingemischt hat wir haben andere
ereignisse erlebt denken wir an prag
1968 denken sie an das kriegsrecht bei
solidarisch denken sie an
1953 in der ddr an ungarn
das waren alles historische
konstellationen in denen die menschen
mit dem gleichen mut im grunde auch
gescheitert sind und danach eine sehr
schwere zeit hatten und auch heute ist
es sind die umstände in weißrussland
nicht so günstig wie sie es 1989 90 im
gesamten damaligen ostblock waren und
trotzdem wünsche ich dass die menschen
einen fortschritt erreichen können also
ich kann mich gut reinversetzen weiß
aber auch wie sehr erfolg und nicht
erfolg sondern so als solcher bewegungen
davon abhängen wie die gesamt
geopolitische lage ist vielleicht
geschockt noch eine nachfrage der
präsident
vom bus herr lukaschenko ist da noch für
sie die deutsche regierung noch einen
gesprächspartner wenn er so dermaßen hat
seine bürger schlagen lässt foltern
lässt sie haben das vielleicht auch
gesehen gehört bleibt sagte spick
partner
die haben mir gesagt dass wir das
ergebnis der wahlen nicht anerkennen als
europäische union
wir glauben dass diese wahlen dieses
wahlergebnis nicht ehrlich ausgezählt
ist auf der anderen seite habe ich auch
selber versucht mit lukaschenko zu
telefonieren er hat das abgelehnt von
seiner seite weil mir natürlich bewusst
ist dass man auch mit den akteuren
überall sprechen muss ich kann ja nicht
nur mit dem russischen präsidenten über
belarus sprechen
das ist finde ich auch nicht angezeigt
insofern aber er hat sich diesem
gespräch bis jetzt noch nicht geöffnet
ich würde es vor allen dingen begrüßen
wenn die osze die ja in dem ganzen
prozess auch vor 30 jahren und davor
eine wichtige rolle gespielt hatte wenn
die osze einen zugang bekommen würde zu
den verschiedenen gruppen in belarus
denn sie ist ja gerade die organisation
die sich historisch auch bewährt hat und
könnte vielleicht jetzt auch eine sehr
wichtige rolle spielen
ich habe jetzt etwa noch 15 fragen auf
der liste und wir haben noch 15 minuten
deswegen bitte ich sie von nachfragen
abzusehen und insbesonders nur die
fragen gestellt werden und ich nicht
mehr an
dann kriegen wir das noch hin aus dem
lachen das jetzt nicht zu erkennen ob
das zustimmung oder ablehnung ist ich
bin im saal bei herrn davis also hoffe
dass ich noch drauf antworten was ich
jetzt frage ich wollte noch mal kurz
zurück zu den finanzen und zwar haben
sie ja ein eher pessimistische prognose
abgegeben was jetzt in herbst und winter
angeht und mona krise und gleichzeitig
achten dass die finanzielle
tragfähigkeit deutschlands schon
herausgefordert ist meine frage ist wo
ist da einig für sie die schmerzgrenze
sie sind ja angetreten mal als kanzlerin
den ausgeglichenen haushalt haben wollte
jetzt mit einem weit weit davon entfernt
man hat so ein bisschen das gefühl dass
man auch so einer abschüssigen straße
gerade ist so der bundesfinanzminister
der ja vielleicht weil bundeskanzler ist
möglicherweise er redet die flotte der
schon mit der idee von euro bonds und es
geht ja alles in so einer ganz anderen
richtung jetzt ich wollte einfach mal
fanden also ich finde gar nicht dass
alles in eine andere richtung geht um
genommen von dem was olaf scholz sagt
also wenn man sich anguckt was passiert
dann hat der deutsche bundestag in der
tat eine ausnahme von der schuldenregel
beschlossen aber auch klare rückzahlungs
pläne und eine rückkehr wieder zu der
schuldenbremse
wenn außergewöhnliche umstände es nicht
ermöglichen auch außergewöhnlich zu
handeln dann macht man politisch etwas
falsch ich bin der festen überzeugung
dass das eine gute entscheidung ist sich
jetzt in hohem maße zu verschulden weil
alles andere uns noch viel länger in der
sozusagen kralle der pandemie halten
würde und wir absolut jetzt richtig
agieren
es ist klar dass dann zu einem
bestimmten zeitpunkt wenn wir in der
phase der wirtschaftlichen erholung
gehen das sicherlich nochmal politische
debatten geben wird was ist jetzt
notwendig was nicht aber ich bin ganz
optimistisch dass uns das gelingt denn
es ist uns ja auch gelungen in der
internationalen finanzkrise wenngleich
die herausforderung jetzt viel viel
größer ist damals 1 5 millionen
kurzarbeiter jetzt im
wie also jetzt auf dem höhepunkt über
sechs millionen kurzarbeiter das zeigt
schon jetzt die dimension noch mal
stärker ist und dann sind wir doch auch
wieder in die phase gekommen in der wir
sehr solide gewirtschaftet haben und ich
bin im rückblick geben vor allen dingen
froh dass wir uns nicht haben das süße
gift einreden lassen auch nun macht doch
mal auch in guten zeiten durchaus
schulden und der ausgeglichenen haushalt
ist doch kein wert an sich jetzt zeigt
sich dass es schon sehr richtig war und
dass wir da jetzt sehr viel kraftvoller
in die bekämpfung der pandemie und ihrer
wirtschaftlichen folgen eintreten
konnten schweizer frau bundeskanzlerin
ist ja so langsam ihr letztes jahr in
ihrer langen amtszeit an
es wird ja mit lesen kann leicht ist ein
kein spaziergang macht sich dann
manchmal vielleicht bei ihnen schon
wehmut breit dass sie sagen oh das noch
nicht das letzte mal arbeiten sie alles
ab und dann ist das schon spektakulär im
nächsten herbst von einem traktor den
anschluss und was würden sie sich
wünschen so in der rückschau soll dann
ihre kanzlerschaft daran beteilige ich
mich nicht das überlasse ich ihnen
aber wir haben noch also ich sagte ja
schon neben den normalen aufgaben als
bundeskanzlerin haben wir jetzt ja noch
mal eine ganz spezielle zeit mir ist
sehr wichtig dass ich noch was immer
möglich ist im bereich der
digitalisierung voran bringe es hat sich
jetzt in der kroner pandemie nochmal
dramatischer gezeigt dass wir was
digitalisierung anbelangt gerade der
föderalen ebenen wirklich nicht an der
spitze der bewegung auf der welt stehen
und hier mehr bereitschaft zu erzeugen
das ist für mich noch mal ein ganz
großer ganz große motivation muss ich
sagen genauso wie die entsprechenden so
die technologischen dinge voranzubringen
wasserstofftechnologie unsere großen
strategischen projekte batteriezelle
herstellung und vieles andere mehr
energiewende also im egt arbeit jetzt
sich aus und natürlich weiß ich dass das
jetzt noch ein jahr ist und das bringt
aber auch wieder mit sich dass jeder tag
sehr zählt und man auch keinen
verschwenden möchte sondern ich weiß
wenn du jetzt bei der digitalen bildung
noch was machen sitzt und so dann muss
es auch wirklich gut getaktet sein und
das macht mir freude meine liebe
bewertungen überlasse ich dann wirklich
der außenwelt dann gegen mainz digital
auch noch mal eine frage zum
alltagsgeschäft engagiertes von
deutschlandradio fragt daten aus
polizeicomputer werden abgerufen
menschen erhalten drohmails viele people
of colour beklagen strukturellen
rassismus in den sicherheitsbehörden und
der insel minister weigert sich eine
studie zum rezept offering durchführen
zu lassen
wie groß ist aus ihrer sicht das problem
des rassismus in sicherheitsbehörden
und was sagen sie den betroffenen ich
denke dass man gegen die
sicherheitsbehörden keinen
generalverdacht haben darf aber dass man
sehr sehr aufmerksam diese hier
genannten entwicklungen verfolgen muss
und da sehr genau hin kommen in gruppen
muss ich bin sehr erfreut das bundesamt
für verfassungsschutz das jetzt auch
eine große priorität hat und ich finde
es richtig und damit haben wir auch
politisch reagiert dass wir einen
kabinettsausschuss rechtsradikalismus
und rassismusbekämpfung haben der dieser
kabinettsausschuss wird nächste woche
mittwoch tagen und wird dann auch ein
hearing mit gesellschaftlichen gruppen
haben es ist sehr viel vorbereitet
werden jetzt mit den verschiedenen
betroffenen gruppen und ich bin sehr
gespannt auf das was wir hören denn hier
muss jeder hinweis extrem ernst genommen
werden die nsu erfahrungen sagen uns ja
dass wir gerade im föderalen staat auf
die auf die vernetzten muster nicht
sehen und deshalb muss das mit aller
kraft angegangen werden und deshalb ist
der nächste mittwoch für mich dann ganz
wichtiger punkt um dann auch zu
entscheiden was wir daraus
schlussfolgern an aktionen die wir auch
im bundes der bundesregierung machen
können oder mit den ländern zusammen
machen
wichtig ist natürlich dass unsere
polizei auch die entsprechenden
möglichkeiten bekommt den dingen auf die
spur zu kommen und auf den grund zu
gehen und da spielt die verabschiedung
des bundes verfassungsschutzgesetz das
jetzt schon eine sehr große rolle
das ist weit gediehen und ich hoffe dass
wir das dann auch bald im kabinett
beschließen können dann bin ich vom
schwaaner fischwaren chinas guten tag
frau kessel meiner frage handelt sich um
die szenario beziehung aus die us-
präsident wird deutschland die europa
china zusammenarbeit verstärken und die
gemeinsamen herausforderungen zu
bewältigen zum beispiel das viewty
tourismus im westen und so weiter an
stärke
ja wir hatten uns ja für unsere
ratspräsidentschaft sehr viel
vorgenommen wollten den eu china gipfel
abhalten in leipzig das kann jetzt
leider nicht passieren wegen der korona
pandemie aber die themen bleiben wir auf
der tagesordnung und ich sehe vor allen
dingen die möglichkeit dass wir in
klimaschutz enger zusammenarbeiten
ich hoffe und darüber werden wir auch
dann den nicht sprechen dass wir beim
investitionsschutzabkommen weiter kommen
an dem wir ja schon seit vielen jahren
mit einer
da verhandeln und wir wollten uns auch
darüber verständigen wie wir die dritt
staatspolitik machen zum beispiel das
engagement europas und auch chinas in
afrika
wir müssen aber auch über themen
sprechen wo wir unterschiedliche
meinungen haben
dazu gehört auch manches was jetzt in
hongkong passiert deutschland
unterstützt das thema ein land zwei
systeme aber wir wollen dass die dass
die vertragliche grundlage das haben mit
hongkong auch wirklich eingehalten wird
und hier gibt es durchaus auch
meinungsverschiedenheiten aber
nichtsdestotrotz wollen wir das gespräch
fortsetzen und vor allen dingen auch
einen akzent für multilateralismus
setzen mit fairen rahmenbedingungen und
einem reziproken herangehen der fahrer
hat er frau bundeskanzler ich würde auch
noch mal gerne auf den berühmt
gewordenen satz den sie ihr 2015
gesprochen haben zurückkommen
sie erwähnten muss der rückschau ein
paar positive beispiele aber es gibt ja
auch negatives also immer noch sind drei
viertel aller hier lebenden für beziehen
hartz 4
es gibt über 200.000 ausreisepflichtige
aber nur 20.000 abschiebung es gibt
höhere kriminalität anteile können sie
vielleicht noch einmal präzisieren
ihren optimismus was wir an geschaffen
haben müssen oder was wir wann schaffen
ja wir haben hier natürlich gibt es auch
probleme das wäre ja auch bei einer
solchen herausforderung ganz
ungewöhnlich wenn es keine gebe die gibt
es ja in allen bereichen die wir
anpacken gibt es auch probleme gibt es
dinge die noch nicht gelöst sind und
nach wie vor ist das thema der
rückführung von menschen die keinen auf
den stadtstaat keinen dauerhaften
aufenthaltsstatus bei uns haben ein
thema das uns beschäftigt das wird bei
der migrations agenda der kommission
auch eine große rolle spielen wir haben
mit einigen ländern durchaus solche
abkommen abschliessen können mit anderen
noch nicht oft sind ja auch die
bedingungen in den herkunftsländern sehr
sehr schlecht wenn es um kriminelle
fragen geht dann muss man natürlich mit
der gleichen härte des gesetzes
reagieren als wenn das menschen sind die
schon sehr viele jahre bei uns leben und
wir haben natürlich auch nicht alle die
jetzt abitur machen und schon die
sprache total toll bei herrschen ich
glaube wir haben sehr viel gemacht bei
den integrationskursen und es wird jetzt
auch eine phase kommen
durch die höhere arbeitslosigkeit
insgesamt in deutschland ist natürlich
die möglichkeit menschen in arbeit zu
bringen die mit einer kurzfristigen also
die noch nicht so lange bei uns sind und
hier als flüchtlinge oder migranten
angekommen sind noch mal schwieriger ich
bin trotzdem sehr froh dass wir ja doch
einiges auch zuwege gebracht haben zum
beispiel das zuwanderungsgesetz
wir haben einen ganz anderen ansatz auch
an die gesamte frage der zuwanderung und
trotzdem wird uns das thema weiter
begleiten und auch in den nächsten
jahren begleiten denn das thema flucht
und vertreibung ist ja nicht beendet so
ein langes thema des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert seien letztlich nur dadurch
bewältigt werden können wenn wir bessere
lebenschancen auch in den
herkunftsländern für die menschen haben
die zu uns kommen hier täglich nach
deutschen weil der frau bundeskanzlerin
taiwan betrachtet die chinesischen
manöver vor der eigenen küste als
provokation
werden sie das verhalten chinas als
akzeptabel und sind sie sich eigentlich
sicher dass europa sich nicht am ende
doch zwischen den usa und china
entscheiden
europa müsste sich dann zwischen usa und
china entscheiden wenn es wirtschaftlich
schwach ist wenn es bestimmte
technologien nicht selber hat und
deshalb ist ja die europäische agenda
absolut richtig auch unabhängige
fähigkeiten und fertigkeiten zu
entwickeln das heißt cloud computing sei
science andere dinge wenn wir permanent
in die frage getrieben werden dass wir
uns zwischen europa und zwischen china
und den usa entscheiden wäre das für das
selbstverständnis europas nicht gut wir
haben mit den usa natürlich eine
gemeinsame wertebasis zwischen eu und
china haben wir total unterschiedliche
gesellschaftliche systeme und wir
versuchen natürlich hier auch gerade uns
einzusetzen auch jetzt im blick auf
taiwan für das geltung des
internationalen rechts ich habe immer
wieder auch bedauert dass china sich
nicht auch den dem der rechtsprechung
geht es internationalen seegerichtshof
sun schließt das würde vieles verbessert
als das würde vieles erleichtern aus
meiner sicht drei fragen an die ersten
digitalen ich habe noch eine frage zum
klimaschutz das umweltbundesamt
empfiehlt ein tempolimit auf autobahnen
als wirksam wird kurzfristig
realisierbaren beitrag zur reduzierung
der treibhausgasemissionen sollte
deutschland ihrer meinung nach ein
solches tempolimit einführen
ich persönlich bin der meinung dass die
heute gängigen angepassten
geschwindigkeiten die auch sehr
variieren können mit der tageszeit
ausreichen um vernünftigen verkehrsfluss
hinzubekommen schließe mich also der
empfehlung im augenblick nicht an
einige ja stefan reinecke hat frau
merkel noch eine frage zur
flüchtlingspolitik die situation in den
griechischen lagern ist nach wie vor
schwierig teilweise katastrophal
es gibt kommunen und zwei bundesländer
thüringen und berlin die signalisiert
haben mehr flüchtlingen für andere
kinder aufzunehmen die bundesregierung
möchte das nicht
halten sie das für klug und mit dem
selbstbild einer christlichen partei für
vereinbar
ich halte das für richtig weil wir ja
politisch zwei dinge erreichen müssen
das eine ist dass deutschland seiner
verantwortung gerecht wird das andere
aber auch dass die dass wir in richtung
einer europäischen lösung arbeiten und
es ist sehr anerkennenswert dass es
bundesländer oder kommunen gibt die
sagen wir würden gerne mehr flüchtlinge
aufnehmen wenn sich aber in europa herum
spricht das in deutschland dass alle
flüchtlinge die hier zur debatte stehen
von deutschland aufgenommen werden dann
werden wir nie eine europäische lösung
bekommen und ich finde das ist eine
herausforderung für uns alle in europa
und deshalb ist der bundesinnenminister
natürlich der die institution die genau
da den brückenschlag finden muss
zwischen den lokalen bereitschaften und
den europäischen gegebenheiten und
deshalb handelt er da richtig das muss
immer in einklang gebracht werden
außerdem ist es natürlich so dass die
bereitschaft der bundesländer dann
manchmal auch darin mündet dass sie
anschließend die bundesregierung um
finanzielle unterstützung fragt auch da
muss man glaube ich wirklich mit offenen
karten spielen man kann nicht
unbegleitete minderjährige kinder
aufnehmen um anschließend dann zu sagen
jetzt wollen wir aber gerne dass die
unbegleiteten minderjährigen kinder auch
mit bundesanteil finanziert werden und
wenn es zum beispiel dann auch im
hartz-iv-bezug oder ähnliches geht sind
es auch die beitragszahler das heißt wir
müssen das auch immer
gesamtgesellschaftlich abwägen
ich gebe ihnen aber recht dass die
zustände gerade in den griechischen
lagern sehr unzumutbar sind deshalb hat
deutschland ja auch schon einiges getan
und wird auch weiteres du dann bin ich
ihnen sage hat man gemerkt zum abschluss
hansestadt noch eine persönliche frage
zu corona nicht interessiert was sie
also den menschen angela merkel
eigentlich am meisten in dieser zeit
nervt was sie am meisten vermissen in
ihrem leben spontane begegnungen dass
man immer gucken muss wie verhalte ich
mich jetzt also diese spontaneität in
begegnungen mit anderen menschen
die vermisse ich am meisten dann würde
ich im anbetracht der zeit mit dieser
knappen letzten frage und knappen
letzten antwort schließen
vielen dank für ihr kommen ich bitte sie
um verständnis dass wir nicht alle
fragen beantworten konnten zumal aus dem
digitalen frau bundeskanzlerin dennoch
vielen dank für ihre zeit und wir
wünschen ihnen noch einen schönen
nachmittag und ein schönes staaten
sorgen
ja danke schön und gleichfalls möglichen
wünschen auch an die die digital
gemeldet weiß man ja nicht